[Música]
si tomemos el punto más importante que
es
el trabajar comunicar hablar decir
buscar algo para alguien encontrar no sé
sentido lógico de la abogacía
abogado aquel que habla en favor y o por
otro
en las profesiones que han servido para
conciliar para estar para dar para
conjuntar
una mejor sociedad mejores comunidades
desde el origen
desde el origen del hombre se ha venido
dando siempre que alguien busque tener
una interlocución por otro cuando ha
habido una falta de comunicación
esto es el origen y así sea con el
devenir histórico así ha sido siempre
en la historia de la abogacía
se va yo también la dificultad de aquel
que aboga o habla o trabaja por otro
para conseguir un objetivo para salvar
un obstáculo para concretar una
negociación para dirimir una
controversia para buscar una solución en
algo
porque será la colegiación en qué
momento encontramos ese origen de la
colegiación como en nuestro país que es
uno de los primeros países en la
historia de la humanidad que tiene una
colegiación cerca por torreal
pero la razón por la cual
se logra que el rey
provea a los abogados de colegiación es
para evitar que los abogados que hayan
caído o bien en desgracia o los
familiares de los abogados que no tienen
hoy a un profesional a su profesional
que les proveía la manutención no tengan
que estar mendigando en la audiencia
pública por recursos para poder
sobrevivir así se da una orden real y se
crea el primer colegio en la historia de
las américas que se disgusten nacional
colegio abogado soy ilustres real
colegio de abogados de méxico el cual
presido
a esta creación y entonces tiene una
vocación muy importante
la colegiación en este momento
qué platicar en brevemente como sea
también el devenir histórico qué es lo
que sucede
entonces los abogados empiezan a tener
no solamente una interrelación con todo
el gremio con todas las disciplinas
jurídicas
las autoridades judiciales también con
los justiciables y empiezan a crear ese
ese gremio que ya les provee de muchas
cosas que podrían faltar si el
profesional el profesionista deja de
percibir un recurso y así se da la
mutualidad así se da la educación
continua así en estos albores ser la
integración de garcía frente a la
sociedad y se vuelve un actor
contundente con el poder
viene esa evolución y cuando mido
momentos difíciles de los
gobiernos de los regímenes de esas
transiciones de poder
se han vuelto los abogados un factor muy
importante para buscar que se preserven
el estado de derecho de los más
incipientes estados de derechos hasta
los más difíciles cuando han sido
realmente vulnerados y los dos se han
vuelto un objetivo del poder cuando éste
ha sido dictatorial cuando éste no
respeta el jurídico y es cuando son
atacados les puedo decir que en la
experiencia de inducción nacional
colegio abogados que si bien tuvo
incluso presidentes de la república que
fueron miembros del colegio también tuvo
el poder político el poder público la
intención de acabar con la colegiación y
los abogados por
y los dos tenemos como obligación buscar
el acceso a la justicia
todos los justicia desde todos los
ciudadanos ha sucedido y se han de poder
entrar a las autoridades los actores
políticos de aplastar a los abogados
es sin duda muy importante que los
abogados
que debemos ser custodios del estado de
derecho y hoy en el estado democrático
de derecho tengamos que enfrentar al
poder cuando se tenga que enfrentar
tengo que contener al poder cuando se
deberá contener tengamos que acompañar e
incluso dirigir para que se preserven el
marco jurídico correcto para que se
preserven el estado democrático de
derecho a la propia autoridad y busca
estado democrático de derecho significa
tener un equilibrio de los tres poderes
en todo el ejecutivo del legislativo y
del judicial que intromisión como las
hemos estado viendo
del ejecutivo en los otros dos poderes y
deberemos ejercitar las acciones que
sean necesarias
preserva no se lo puedo decir con
orgullo que agrupa todos los colegios de
abogados agrupando a todas las
instituciones de abogados agro para
agrupando también a todas las
disciplinas jurídicas estamos creando
una fuerza en contra del gobierno no
sino un ni gremial que permita un mejor
desarrollo social y que desde nuestra
trinchera podamos trabajar de manera
contundente en favor de la misma
sociedad
participación con viento las actividades
dejarles una reflexión una reflexión
importante somos la única profesión que
detenta un poder
y es el poder judicial para formar parte
del poder judicial sea juez sea
magistrado o sea ministro es obligación
es requisito
puede ser simplemente un ingeniero o una
persona común y corriente para poder ser
juez magistrado o ministro detentamos
uno de los poderes es una gran
responsabilidad y si esto le sumamos que
en todas las dependencias del poder
ejecutivo existe cuando menos un abogado
sea director jurídico sea consejero
jurídico se sigue incrementando nuestra
participación en las acciones del
gobierno y viendo todavía más lejos en
el poder legislativo existe también una
obligación para que una de las
comisiones tenga un apoyo de un
consejero jurídico es decir que tenemos
una participación activa en otros
poderes tenemos una gran responsabilidad
y son los tres niveles de gobierno
los los abogados hoy el trabajo que
hacemos con la colegiación vamos hacia
la autorregulación que mejor que el
abogado regule a sus padres que en
comunión del trabajo con el esfuerzo
propio tengamos una autorregulación que
permita nuestro ejercicio desde una
ética que a toda la sociedad pero sobre
todo que vele por la sociedad que vele
por el estado de derecho estemos
participando
esto conllevará también en esa
transición tenemos la obligación en
nuestra autorregulación
certificamos y con qué nos vamos a
certificar pues nos debemos de
certificar con las instituciones de
educación con las escuelas de derecho
con las universidades con las facultades
de derecho
siempre de la mano con quien de la
educación no también de como un acuerdo
por otro después de llegar a la
certificación de los abogados debemos de
tener una colegiación obligatoria es
colegiación obligatoria tiene que venir
desde el órgano regulador de la
educación en este caso aceite de
educación pública en comunión con el
órgano auto regulador que son los
colegios de abogados para que tengan un
certificación y colegiación y la
sociedad que es el usuario de los
servicios que nosotros prestamos tenga
certeza que está contratando a un
profesional capacitado un profesional
que tiene una buena reputación y que
cumple con la encomienda que le da para
poder siempre cumplir el trabajo pero
sobre todo
auxiliar a la comunidad auxiliar a la
sociedad
tenemos una responsabilidad social es
responsabilidad social es importante que
somos uno de los ejes que permite que se
trabaje y que se viva que se conviva que
se logre la social sí tenemos respeto a
nuestro marco jurídico si podemos
nosotros
hacer que la sociedad entienda
que el abogado es importante por el
trabajo que desempeñen tendremos éxito
en nuestra gestión pero antes de eso
tenemos que ser lo suficientemente
claros y honestos
reconocer a la sociedad que en ocasiones
hemos fallado en número de ocasiones el
cumplido por eso se ha manifestado la
misma sociedad de una forma graciosa
porque también tenemos una cultura que
es la mofa expresándose de los abogados
tenemos nosotros la obligación de
cambiar el sentido de esa percepción
social porque es una realidad podemos
decir que todo ha sido maravilloso no
hemos tenido una problemática nosotros
en el devenir histórico muy muy
preocupante porque porque se ha llevado
de la mano con los actos que vulneran a
nuestra sociedad como la corrupción un
flagelo nacional sin duda también los
sufragio internacional pero tenemos que
trabajar primero con nosotros porque
medida lo que no tienen y después que lo
estamos haciendo y después
trabajar y lograr que el colega sea
respetado especialmente por las
autoridades y evidentemente en esa
actualidad que se tiene de gobernante y
gobernado por la misma sociedad y somos
un factor somos un factor para que esto
se cumpla y debemos ser respetuosísimos
sí pero también debemos responder a la
sociedad que nos lo pide hoy más que
ayer con exigencia porque porque se
siente se vive y en el devenir de todos
los días en esta actualidad
sabemos que hay factores que hay
elementos que rompen la estructura
social y en que no se pueda vivir
cómodamente porque porque el primer el
primer rompimiento social se da con la
inseguridad
cuando se respetan las leyes también
tenemos la obligación que en el cole gal
se generen oportunidades que dentro de
esa
10ª situación que jurídica frente a
todos no solamente tener
los ciudadanos oportunidades sino que
también podemos tener una convivencia en
paz podamos tener una convivencia que
permita nuestro desarrollo personal no
solamente es la oportunidad de trabajo
no es solamente la oportunidad de tener
un salario o estar bien remunerados sino
de tener esparcimiento de lograr una
convivencia familiar y poder desarrollar
a las comunidades en cualquiera de las
regiones de nuestro país
con un punto muy importante que es la
obligación mayor que tenemos hoy los
abogados frente a la sociedad y todos
aquellos que han tomado la decisión
detrás
a favor de la legalidad de trabajar en
el ejercicio profesional debemos de
prever y debemos de proveer dos cosas
uno que se cumple con la ley y dos que
todo mundo tenga acceso a la justicia y
es un único informe pero esa
responsabilidad
de nosotros frente
a nuestros seres queridos a nuestros
compañeros de trabajo a nuestras
comunidades pero es una exigencia
de convivencia y de desarrollo
lograremos y no tendremos éxito si no
logramos el acceso a la justicia de
todos los mexicanos
gracias
[Aplausos]